-Here's how the game works.
Tina and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us have seen before.
It could be people,
objects, anything.
Taking turns, we'll have
45 seconds to try to get
the other person to guess
what's behind them.
Tina, if you don't mind,
I'll guess first.
-Okay.
-Let's get into position.
So, I -- Oh!
Oh, this thing moves.
Ohh!
-High-tech.
-[ Giggling ] Okay. Okay.
-All right, now, Tina,
when the curtain opens,
you pick up that card.
And it has to be
the exact phrase.
You have to get me to guess.
-I have to get you
to say the phrases.
-The phrase that's on the card.
-Okay.
-Time starts
when you start talking.
Now let's open the curtain
and see what's behind me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay, so...
Okay. This is a large --
a large monkey from the movies.
King Kong.
-Yes, yes.
And he's holding a giant version
of something that you eat
that's not a hamburger...
-A hot dog?
-Yes!
-And that thing is wearing
something that
fancy gentlemen wear.
-They're wearing a cap.
-Mr. Peanut wears one.
-Mr. Peanut wears a top hat.
-Yes! Yes!
-So it's King Kong eating
a hot dog with a top hat?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I didn't realize
it's going to be real.
I thought it was
gonna be, like, a picture.
[ Laughter ]
-I had no idea.
-That guy's at work right now.
That's his job.
-He gets paid for that.
-That's his job.
-It is your turn to guess.
Let's rotate.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-This is high-tech, man.
It's big-budget, man.
-Ahh!
-This is big-budget stuff.
-All right. Here we go.
All right. All right.
I'll be good at this.
Here we go. Ready?
Please open the curtain.
Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Famous movie scene about --
-"Gone with the Wind."
-No, a romantic comedy,
a romantic movie.
-Like top of the
Empire State Building?
-Whoopi Goldberg was in it.
-"Ghost." Pottery wheel.
-Except it's two famous,
uh, uh, aliens.
-Two famous aliens?
-Who's the most famous
movie alien?
-E.T.?
-Yes.
-Two E.T.s doing pottery.
-And it's not at the wintertime.
It is the --
-Summer.
-And where does the sun shine?
-On the beach.
-Yes, that's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-Wow.
-I mean, again --
There are two things.
One, you can't unsee that.
And then --
-And it's surprisingly sexy.
[ Laughter ]
-Please close that curtain!
Oh, my goodness.
Close that curtain, please!
I'm so sorry that
everyone had to see that
and America had to see that.
-Sorry, everybody.
-All right. I'm up again.
Let's spin this.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
-All right. All right.
All right.
-Okay.
-Please open the curtain.
Okay. Okay.
All right. This is the, uh --
Okay.
It's a guy who's very jolly.
-Santa Claus.
-Yes.
And he's in a place where
white people enjoy themselves.
-Starbucks.
-White people enjoy themselves
until the Williams sisters
come along.
[ Laughter ]
-Wimbledon?
-Yeah, but that --
-Tennis. A tennis match.
-Yeah.
The place.
-A tennis court.
-Yes, and he's holding a thing
that everyone likes to joke down
but it's actually awesome.
-A Shake Weight.
[ Laughter ]
-You send it to people.
Like, you send it
to your grandma,
and it's like,
"Happy Mother's Day."
You can eat this.
-[ Laughs ] I've never sent
that to my grandma, ever.
-It looks like flowers,
but it's not flowers.
-Oh, it's edible arrangements!
-Yes!
-Oh, yes!
That's what I thought.
♪♪
Looks like he's gonna throw it.
-He's gonna whip it at us.
-He looks like he's gonna
whip it at me. It's weird.
Is that the same guy
that was the hot dog?
-Yeah.
Quick change.
-Unbelievable. All right.
It's time for the final round.
Let's spin this.
-We win a car at
the end of this, right?
-Yes.
-Everyone wins a car.
-Everyone needs
to share one car.
It's a minivan.
-Okay.
All right.
I'm getting ready for this.
Okay. All right.
Uh, Alexa,
please open the curtain.
Please open the curtain.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tina laughs ]
-Okay. Uh...
Uh, uh, uh,
famous British invasion.
-The Beatles.
-Yes.
They're not in the beach,
but they are in the --
-The snow.
-Yes.
And they're using a toy
that was popular in the '50s
that you use your hips --
-"Howdy Doody." A hula hoop.
-Yes, that's correct!
The Beatles hula-hooping
in the snow!
Very nice. Beatles.
[ Laughs ]
That is fantastic right there.
That is as sexy as E.T. was,
just the opposite.
-It's the opposite. My thanks
to Tina Fey right there.